We've learned how to use build types
to customize Gradle's behavior.
So now let's look at how build variants
allow you to control the behavior of
your app itself.
And depending on which
app we're building,
the Android Gradle plugin creates
a whole slew of source sets.
And depending on which variant you're
building, it will merge the sources and
resources from those source
sets into the final APK.
At the most broad level,
there's the main source set
which is located in source main.
This is where we've been
putting all of our code so far.
Additionally, there's a source set for
each product flavor.
Assuming our example from before,
let's say we have a free and
a paid product flavor.
There's also a source set for each build
type, in this case debug and release.
Finally there's also a source for
each final variant.
So that's source free debug, free
release, paid debug, and paid release.
If we have sources and resources
that we need in a paid flavor but
not in the free flavor,
we can put them in source paid.
Similarly, if there are resources
we need for debug build but not for
the release build,
we can put them in source debug.
Finally, if we have resources
that are needed only for
the paid debug variant, then we can
put them in the source paid debug.
When we build a particular variant,
Gradle will take care of all
the emerging sources and
resources we need for that variant.
It will also take care of a variety of
resources that are defined in more than
one configuration.
The rule is that the more
specific configurations
override the less
specific configurations.
Java's source files
cannot be overwritten, so
you need to be careful that you don't
try to define the same class definition,
and it ends up in multiple variants.
Gradle can do a bit better for
resource files like strings.xml, or
even Android Manifests.
For resources of that type,
the files will be merged, and
the entries will be overridden by ID.
To determine what sources and resources
are included when we build a particular
variant, we can draw a diagram
that looks like this.
We start in the middle.
If we want to build the paid debug
variant, Gradle will include everything
in main, then merge everything in paid,
overriding any conflicts.
Next Gradle will merge in everything
from debug overriding again.
Then, finally,
Gradle will merge in the resources and
source that are in paid debug.